on the take-off on the taxi we heard an
explosion that's Jennifer Aniston
getting candid about one seriously scary
birthday trip to Mexico in February the
actress stopped by her good friend Jimmy
Kimmel's Late Show on Thursday alongside
her murder mystery co-star Adam Sandler
and she recalled a girls getaway gone
wrong Jen was with her close gal pals
who surprised her with the 50th birthday
trip including Courtney Cox and Ginny's
wife Molly McNerney on the take off on
the taxi we heard an explosion which
sounded like a pothole if it was a car
big enough to go over the Grand Canyon
it was that loud a former friend star
who said she already had a fear of
flying was told two hours into the
flight that they had to turn the plane
around and go back to California they
found some debris from a wheel on the
runway they think it's from our plane
everybody starts texting all of a sudden
their spouses yeah yeah so what did
Jimmy say to his wife well Jen was quick
to share his hilarious response which
included a shirtless selfie I said I
just signed up for tinder but I promise
not to activate it until we know what's
one
and it's a good thing they turned back
jimmy shared a pic of the plane they
were on which was missing a tire that's
what you guys landed with no tires
carried on a plane with some of
America's most beloved national toys
yeah meanwhile I signed up for tinder
and it's going great thankfully Jen and
her friends eventually made it safely to
Cabo San Lucas et spoke to Courtney Cox
shortly after the incident and she had
this to say about the emergency landing
all I know is that it was missing the
back right tire but honestly we're very
lucky landing with one tire missing is
not as big a deal as it may sound when
you're on the plane
[Music]